well hello there Mike yes you already
were you my name is Greg I'm Morgan
thank you actually how to use with
Morgan and actually a channel with these
two lovely foxes oh yeah sorry all
flappy compliment and - I'm a dude how
to's with Morgan and Ashley hey so the
guy named Romeo boss Romeo o Romeo said
you got to react as a good morning
t-shirt by McDonald's I think this might
be one of those uh you know Asian
commercials to tend to get people a
little emotional I don't know what this
one is this could be bad for all I know
I do like McDonald's I know I like that
fries and then Ryan left in the ice
cream film
yeah well fat also mom Wow how to get
step so mystery solvers metaphor Oh
funny mommy
la Cucaracha my primary Takapuna hindi
nahi Phoenix on the teepee dilution
master o Appalachian guru from Atlanta
high school
[Music]
biology physics chemistry and general
science as well as a whole different
side on to the patellas and for hours a
civilized man yawning Wow
[Music]
nightmare for the recent Paris after the
decreasing horrible English language and
best birthday began commercial banking
commission carbonic acid attired Armen
Aronov decision under a regarding
invisibility I belong upon mom the
Porsche for example Safinaz Perkins to
support a certain internal minutia Paulo
Roberto hope you mean particle board
members intra c-span traveling Illumina
possum on the body of own lingo her
name's chip Iranian and epigenomic oh I
am I mean art denim Oh an office today
should move my business
[Music]
desire demon enough from classroom on
school - Adam take on time mila kunis
Madonna's without a young mother
basically running final assault
Allah Akbar house make you jumpy but I
know what my mom's happy and there is
nothing but my oh my god I don't want to
go time
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
our she looks so happy
[Music]
McDonald's entertainment and the hole
made always comes I go up I will see
America I'll get my dog guys and
celebrator
why is that mandatory retirement age
I don't know that may be sad is there a
really thorough I see I guess there wow
wow man
well I was really sweet I bet you're
gonna miss all those students that warms
my heart it makes me miss my teachers
high school I was home-schooled and I
see my mom still so yeah but I get it
though remind me of my grandma I'm half
Filipino she looked a lot like my
grandma actually yeah my grandma was
like the caretaker of the entire like
big family you know she's the one who
does not worked her ass off like when
actually in the Philippines when Japan
attacked she was like actually rowing
boats of the bullets fly faster than
[ __ ] like hardcore yeah yeah it's
usually she was 16 or something when
yeah then she was she was the main
breadwinner growing up a family of five
kids and then you know now most people
here in America the legacy continues she
died three years ago
but so many people turned out for her
for her funeral when watching this was
like yeah you know she's my grandma had
like I feel like she had like that kind
of impact on everyone even if yeah even
if he didn't really know her but if she
would somehow around when you were
younger she like affected your life I'm
a major wedding and she took care of me
a lot when I was a baby and she took
care of
all the time so watching this just
reminded me a lot of my grandmommy Lola
I green yeah that what you did we start
so he'll really look great she didn't
get any of my jokes
she and Sweetie good of English oh it
was honest like I always see it in the
smiles here like you know someone who's
so serious it's such a hard worker but
then when you get them to laugh or
something it's just like it just lights
up it's hard because you're like I'm
sorry you seen you be so serious
no matter your feel sovan is she
impacted like that many people they like
also you have a favorite teacher in your
past I will see you actually I still
visit my high school all the time how
old are you 27
I got like I'll go visit and I still
talk to my teachers and my leg I'll
volunteer there and all I'll like talk
to the kids
ballet college and growing up so you
would say you hate the cherishing
although I definitely weird
like so weird we super just like really
barf love as we love each other it was
like girls don't look at me like nothing
are we democra lockers we're all like
trusting and that's a bad way to live
you know life is you graduate her my
school you put your purse down in public
and it's gone exactly but in high school
and you put your purse down and it was
there not my eyes I went the North
Hollywood High in my freshman year named
it stolen from you oh happy yeah someone
but a couple years before I went there
someone got shot on campus Oh killed
actually jeez yeah sorry I do not really
have an impact East Valley actually in
seventh grade okay
I had a teacher named mr. Muller say hey
mr. Muller sure you remember me I like
to write and then I wrote a scene for
class was like an English project and
then we have to have people performance
I liked his last day there he came up to
me and Cole
me what don't give up on your grip
you're gonna go far so and look at him
now yeah writing reactions same exact
thing Oh using your creativity you call
this creativity when I'm doing right now
do you think this is creativity how is
this creativity tell me how does art
work in the back then I did not make my
[Music]
tea again we did have the same master I
was home-schooled it was soon you're mad
Oh daddy with major impact in my life
paddy Claus oh they you see remember
yellow you did I'm Mimi Greg Jeannette
together could it matter we have a
bigger bag but it's awesome that's how
we met because out of Oklahoma school
two actors that's a thing and then we
have the same mass shooter I might be
school but I went to her a lot more than
you yay I saw her all the time and then
I was I was a lot more and so she like
hooked it up I got free well she had to
pay then I got way more but she took
care of me man she took care of me and I
went to Washington I told her I'm going
up there and I paid then she like
visited me she's yeah she's a very
impactful teacher in my life
patty cloth and a lot was my eighth
grade teacher mr. Corda she's young she
was really hot especially for her later
yeah she got mad at me the first 15
minutes of class the first time would
you ever had a teacher well because I
said she's like I'm your new science
teacher and I was like comes eighth
grade kid and I said I was cool we got a
chick for a science teacher
ah and she lay one on me and for the
whole class numbers like establishing
you know that feminist quo
she made an example out of me me oh but
he's like you so glad you think
something but now I'm really grew to
love her a lot of yeah I remember like
the last day of eighth grade like I was
saying bye and we were like she was
crying and we were hugging and stuff she
was amazing had some good teachers some
good teachers I think mrs. Grady field
is my first grade teacher she was
awesome
sometimes I see her I like she lives in
the neighborhood supplemental clearly
Marie Callender's from my mom oh wow
yeah and she remembers me I'm actually
really bad but I'm CLE hey have like no
teachers I went to like I was you were
in the hole for like a hot minute I was
in school I mean I have like a lot of
like really cool like best teachers they
count you know but now I thought the
same thing I'm gonna have a high school
teacher ship Miss Piggy oh I like that
lesson in the natural isn't mrs. Hickey
huh yes that name is interesting but she
was like she's like hardcore neither
hater real ever in my lover I think my
first sexual fantasies might have been
second grade about mrs. Taylor
Oh tonight in it okay in second grade
we're baby how old are you in second
grade eight seven I think here is 14
rooms no do you get held back a lot
better graduate I can good here for
lunch I'm at 27 area I cream in 8th
grade year 14 you're probably like 37
well you know what I watched rated-r
movies I knew what sex was I go to hell
I couldn't actually you know release
anything in second grade but I was doing
sexual things about it Taylor I wonder
if she's still out there
mrs. Taylor okay
to interrupt yeah what was their first
name you know I have so many that think
about that when you're younger like your
teachers were probably and they're like
a late twenties yeah oh we're old now
guys all right well let's go get some
McDonald's
yeah the fries variety ice cream cones
yeah have a coke I like the double cheek
I have had a McDonald burgers Oh chicken
nuggets I could taste it commercial or
worse we're just plenty in the
Philippines like as a commercial yeah
like you're watching a rerun
they usually have like special
commercials for like a special event of
something that well it was breakfast day
yeah this is breakfast day so she wakes
up so early so she gets McDonald's
breakfast you know we missed that part
and then this happened and then
McDonald's breakfast sponsored her
people pretty really wow that's awesome
Mekons you guys have a heart because
father just my lunch I'm Filipino these
are the Philippines and McDonald's this
is something we have in common
my people love McDonald's and you people
white McDonald's chicken we deal so we
have we can accept each other and then
follow your options now too
they do they have like the snack craft
thing which is just like a tortilla and
like grilled chicken I had a salad there
one yeah what do you might see I mean
I'll go there to like it helps you do it
I didn't have it was really it was
harder to be with people who stopped
there and you are against it you can you
two can have a healthy option or just
person grew it in three coats it freakin
fries the girl chick in like like I know
like a not good grilled chicken
leave their chicken I do yeah we start
talking about a McDonald's on this video
subscribe to the real I think nothing
but good things about me go that's all I
love their fries how to use a Morgan and
Ashley on their YouTube channel when
life hands you Morgan on Instagram okay
good photos on there I like a photo
Ashley ender is in Star Trek beyond oh
yeah main character she plays Kirk never
acted on that one if you guys can
screenshot a little Windham actually you
know what scenes are in I'm at Kirk's
birthday party oh yeah yeah if you can
screenshot it and then send it to Morgan
or actually preferably actually shoot to
do well shout you out in her next video
yes you can spot which character she is
like a fun game yeah yeah get them you
know interactive oh so you doing